CARTER MORGAN: Welcome to Cloud
Security Basics, a new series
where we explain the
ins and outs of securing
your application
on Google Cloud.
Sound fun?
Then stick around,
because in this episode,
you'll learn about the second
of three distinct areas of cloud
security risk--
data.
[MUSIC PLAYING]
[DIAL TONE]
BRAD ACTOR: Hello,
cloud detective.
You may have found protections
for the first cloud security
risk-- access.
But how much have you thought
about the second risk--
data?
How can you prevent problems
with the data you store?
There are many ways
to get trapped here.
Improper disclosure of
your info by employees.
Imagine accidentally sending
an email containing credit card
or social security numbers.
Your application could
disseminate harmful data,
sharing phishing
URLs or malware.
Or, data could be
stored somewhere
without proper security
protocols in place.
What can you do to stop that?
For your data's sake,
I hope, you know,
the answer to my question.
CARTER MORGAN:
Here's what we know.
Data represents what data gets
stored and where it's located.
You must be sure
that you don't store
personally identifiable
information, or PII, which
is data that could potentially
be used to identify a user.
And even if you don't store
sensitive information,
if you can't find
where you stored it,
that's not gong to
be very useful to you
or your customers.
Typical concerns here include
something bad with the people
who can access
machines-- for example,
a compromised employee
accessing data they shouldn't.
Something bad with the data
itself, like receiving bad data
or storing illegal data.
If the data coming into
your system is junk,
then even if every other
component of data security
is working as normal,
the system still
won't function as intended.
Sometimes unsanitized
data can even
be used to exploit a system to
further compromise application.
Something bad with the
transfer or storage of data,
for example, not being able
to find where data is stored.
In this case, the Cloud
solution would be losing data,
whether because it
never got stored,
or because it got
lost once it was.
Either way, the end result
is that the data you need
can't be retrieved.
Something bad with
the machine data
is being stored on, like
it containing malware,
or if there were
compromised VMs.
In this case, even though
the data is stored correctly,
it might be leaked or
accessed by the wrong people.
Luckily, Google Cloud provides
a lot of tools and services
to protect its users, including
but not limited to IAM
for controlling access
to data resources,
encryption to make sure
stored and transferred
data can't be read,
even if it is stolen,
logging and monitoring to make
sure that you can track what's
happening in your system.
DeID for making sure PII
information is stripped
before it's ever
stored in your system,
organizational
policy to set rules
on who can access what
data and where it's stored,
and better VMs or VM management,
like for SETI or Google
Host Patching, et
cetera, to make sure
that the machines
you use are secure.
Let's see how they work.
So how do we prevent
problems with data we store?
I just listed a few tools.
I want to highlight
a few of them.
Cloud IAM lets you
grant granular access
to specific Google
Cloud resources
and helps prevent access
to other resources.
Cloud IAM lets you adopt
the security principle
of least privileged,
where you only
grant necessary permissions
to access specific resources.
This works to prevent
people from accidentally
or maliciously accessing
data they shouldn't.
For example, IAM lets
you keep UI developers
from accessing credit card
databases they didn't need
to access in the first place.
Say there was an access
violation, though.
That's where logging
and monitoring
can be used to track
who is accessing what
and to automate the information
gathering and alerting process
as much as possible.
Cloud platform provides tools,
such as Google Cloud Logging
and Google Cloud
Monitoring, that
make it easy to collect
and analyze request logs
and monitor the availability of
your infrastructure services,
like VM instances.
These tools make it easy for
you to create custom dashboards
and set alerts
when issues occur.
For example, you could
set up notifications
to warn you of suspicious
activity in your system,
or to notify you when
access to a resource
is taking too
long, for instance.
But really, it's good to
be proactive as much as
possible and set up
organizational policy.
An organizational policy is
a centralized configuration
of restrictions on how your
organization's resources can
be used.
They define guardrails
for your development teams
to stay within
compliance boundaries
and help teams move
quickly without worrying
of breaking compliance.
For example, you
could set a policy
to require all newly
created, restarted,
or updated Cloud SQL
instances to use customer
managed encryption keys.
All of these tools and more
work together to protect data.
And that's it!
I know the answer to
Brad Actor's question.
BRAD ACTOR: Hello, detective.
I see you've been busy.
You answered my little question.
What if there's a problem
with the data you store?
You learned that Google
provides a plethora of tools
to help customers protect data,
including IAM, encryption,
logging and monitoring,
organizational policy,
and more.
These features allow
you to make sure
only valid data is
being stored, control
who can access
data that's stored,
and help you find the
data you do store.
Very good, very good.
You've answered
today's question.
But be ready,
because next time, I
want to see what you
know about securing
your virtual and
physical hardware.
CARTER MORGAN: So there you
have it, another episode
of Cloud Security Basics.
Next episode, we'll focus on
the last of three distinct areas
of Cloud security risk--
platform.
In the meantime, if you
want to take a deeper
dive into securing
data in the Cloud,
then check out the article
linked in the description
below.
And stay tuned for the rest
of the Cloud Security Basic
series, because when
it comes to security,
you can't let bad actors win.
[MUSIC PLAYING]